by 2050 there could be more plastic in
the ocean by weight than fish my
solution is definitely one of the
largest threats our oceans face today
every year millions of tons of plastic
flows from rivers into the sea polluting
ecosystems and even getting into the
food chain one group of Engineers is
applying technology in new ways to
tackle plastic pollution rivers are
really the arteries that carry the
plastic from land to sea by stemming the
flow at the source
[Applause]
[Music]
roughly four million people live in the
basin of the Klang River in Malaysia
it's one of the most polluted rivers in
the world this team is trying to clean
it up and stop the rivers harmful waste
from flowing into the ocean they're
pinning their hopes on this rubbish
eating boat called the Interceptor the
river's current directs the debris onto
a barrier from where it's funneled into
the boats conveyor belt this is one of
four boats being trialed by the ocean
cleanup a pioneering engineering company
based in the Netherlands the idea was
dreamt up by Boyan slat who is a 16 year
old school boy decided to dedicate
himself to ridding the ocean of plastic
I went scuba diving in Greece and I was
really hoping to see these these
beautiful things like you've seen the
David Attenborough documentaries and
looked around me and I just saw more
plastic bags than fish and that was
rather disappointed by that and this
question came to mind why can't we just
clean this up since then his
organisation has devised a number of
innovative ways to apply technology to
the problem when we started the ocean
cleanup back in 2013 we said let's focus
our attention on plastic that's already
out there and doesn't go away by itself
yet two years later we realized to rip
the world's oceans of plastic you really
have to do to both the prevention and
the cleanup side and start looking at
the rivers
[Music]
every year millions of tons of plastic
finds its way into the ocean most of
which floats down rivers that run
through heavily populated areas areas
where waste collection systems are
flawed or non-existent meaning millions
of people are forced to use the
waterways as a means of disposal but the
first step to solving the problem is to
understand the scale of it what you see
the first studies that try to estimate
how much plastic is flowing into the
ocean there were of just assumptions
heavily extrapolated over the entire
globe at the beginning there's nothing
better than than those kind of studies
but to truly calculate the amount of
pollution in the rivers they need to be
monitored continuously so the ocean
clean up has come up with a new way to
do just that using a camera monitoring
system that can detect the size and type
of plastic and the speed at which it's
traveling it plans to install these
cameras on bridges above rivers all over
the world in the hope that this will
give a clearer idea of where they should
concentrate their efforts current
analysis suggests that 80% of ocean
plastic comes from around 1,000 rivers
the vast majority of the worst polluting
rivers are in Asia Africa and South
America the Pasig River in Manila is one
of the worst polluters it's calculated
that every year ninety six point five
million kilograms of plastic travels
along the river some of which ends up in
the South China Sea plastic pollutions
impact on tourism fisheries and
governmental cleanup projects is
estimated to have cost coastal countries
around nineteen billion dollars per year
but the long-term environmental effect
could be far greater Matias Eggar is a
lead scientist at the ocean cleanup and
this is what marine based sources of
debris looks like big with his team he's
studying plastics collected from the
so-called Great Pacific Garbage Patch a
1.6 million square kilometers own near
Hawaii littered with marine debris but
the hard work is done in a lab in
Rotterdam
she's extracting the plastics from the
sample she's measuring them to put them
in different size classes and different
types this laborious process allows them
to understand the amount composition and
often the origin of plastic that ends up
in the ocean it looks like Japanese to
me we never see them this size the
impact on marine life is very different
for the different kind of plastic and
also time of sizes if you have very
large pieces of plastic like a ghost
that for example entanglement this main
ways the smaller the plastic pieces the
more impactful they are on an ecosystem
sunlight and seawater can break plastic
down into micro plastics which ocean
creatures often mistake for food when
they eat the plastic they absorb
chemicals that then enter the food chain
the long-term effect of these plastics
in the food chain and on humans are
still unknown there's a lot of research
being done at the moment the tricky part
is blessing it's very diverse
it's not just one type of plastic it
comes in different sizes shapes the data
we have so far indicates there is
potential negative impact on the marine
life so we really need to have an
understanding of how much plastic is
where and what kind of plastic do we
find in a different marine systems
marine compartments interceptor boats
have been installed in rivers in
Malaysia Indonesia Vietnam and the
Dominican Republic where each boat has
been collecting on average fifty
thousand kilograms of rubbish a day so
far we've caught roughly two-thirds off
the plastic that flows by the team
collaborates with governments to ensure
that the plastic collected from the
boats is disposed of at local waste
management facilities but that's not the
end of the ocean cleanups efforts for us
it's not enough to say oK we've taken
out of the rivers so we feel responsible
to actually guarantee that the plastic
doesn't end up back into the river again
the ocean cleanup isn't the only group
that's trying to solve the issue of
plastic pollution in the world's rivers
but it believes they have a solution
that can scale we didn't design it for
one specific River we designed the
Interceptor to work in a fast flowing
river in Thailand versus as well as in a
slow moving River in Indonesia over the
next few years the team plans to gain
more investment through crowdfunding and
independent benefactors to add hundreds
more interceptor boats to its fleet they
also have plans to recycle some of this
plastic and create products that can
sell to make the initiative
self-sufficient
but removing plastic pollution from the
world's dirtiest rivers will take more
than just clever technology with our
interceptors it's not a replacement to
having good infrastructure or good
policy right so what we should believe
is that these things can be
complementary to each other where with
these interceptors a lot of data is
being collected which can actually help
steer the policy and other types of
campaigns of streams until adequate
waste collection is implemented globally
the ocean cleanup will struggle against
the growing tide of plastic but
protectors like boy and [ __ ] are
developing new approaches that could
benefit the ocean for future generations
[Music]
hi I'm Claire and I directed this film
if you want to learn more about other
types of pollution threatening the ocean
and the people work from hard to edgy
cent then click on the link on set if
you want to watch more of the protector
series they click on the other lady
please remember to subscribe and thank
you for watching